if you think about you know
three-year-olds of seven-year-olds II
can go maybe wait till the 13-14 in
Berkeley how we're doing Matt a few
chains
[Music]
what's going on we got hit we got berkos
popcorn the best popcorn in the history
of the universe ever we got our
world-famous best ever mix here this is
a mix of our caramel corn and our
world-famous white cheddar this is my
number one seller for real that's good
thank you think we can share with Nyjah
that's what I heard he might be a little
that's insanely good this is just $6 get
in my store moving the Eider prices yeah
reasonable not too bad then we got our
way to expensive white truffle as always
doing this to the man how much is that
one at six two in the store just plainly
is crazy so now we came to show you our
most expensive not porn in the world
so first of all we use the most
expensive salt in the world
this is flown in special from a small
island in Denmark called lace oh and
this salt right here is $10 a pound on
taste how do I like them this is really
lucky putting some drugs and
so the next part that makes it the most
expensive is we got real edible 23-karat
gold plate okay okay I don't know about
this you know about I mean go you've
eaten go before yeah I've even go I've
been going with a burger okay have you
go on Sunday yeah I heard about that
I've eaten go just going hard in the
bedroom chain in the mouse so just I've
never eaten gold before it you're
getting it on this is that toast nuts
the other side my everybody ain't doing
this man no playing around you basically
like them on me go
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah take your light go so this
depending on the spot price of gold 125
do 150 dollars and Graham Wow unless you
know that you bring my gold bar I'm
gonna lick it
so change single kernel salt gold I get
the [ __ ] out people come in and pay five
hours for this one time yep can you
believe that somebody bought a kernel of
popcorn with gold and expensive salt for
five dollars
the bad part about this nigel's you
can't split this that's all you're weird
it's always about me being the host of
the show
this is the part that you won't be able
to indulge in but you can tell all your
partners and it tastes really a big
thing so let's see how they got the
strong kind of place here yeah I didn't
bring enough to share chains so you have
more dough we got more of that so this
can right here $500 how long so you have
a deal we're gonna do it we're gonna
volume this you're gonna guys are
friends I mean don't you have something
that looks man that looks look at it
where I make it look
change that I'd buy this just to like
set on my counter for a party or
something for five hundred right that's
a good deal
it's all these gold on your fingers
it matches the ring set man I know y'all
want to try this
it doesn't look expensive Brooke look at
the look at the particle oh boy have $5
kernels yeah gold on I think it makes my
skin shine and glisten all my records
they eventually go gold or platinum yeah
go an internet like the most expensive
salt from Denmark and he gave me like an
ounce of it and I pray that LAX
don't stop me and think of something
else popcorn do you think you'll pay
five hundred dollars for some popcorn
talk to me a minute let me know $5.00
per UD